do you find yourself struggling with one
size fits all policy controls that don't
allow for customization by different
departments or needs
policy controls enable you to control
the type of certificates that your ca
pool can issue
policy controls are one of two types
there's course grained or what we
generally refer to as issuance policies
which have constraints that apply to all
certificate issuance from the entire ca
pool
and there's fine grained which are
represented using templates
these determine the operations a
particular user can perform on a ca pool
think of fine-grained policies as a way
to segment based on conditions and user
groups
many solutions today don't discriminate
between fine and coarse-grained which
means that every department or service
that needs a certificate has to use the
issuance policy that has been assigned
to the whole company or service
for example
policies applied to employees in
accounting may be different from
engineers working in prod but the same
ca serves both of them this inefficiency
leads to needing multiple scoped cas for
different use cases and manual
processing of each certificate request
the good news is with cas you can use
coarse and fine-grained policy controls
together to have even more control over
the certificate issuance process and set
different restrictions for different
needs
for today's video we'll focus on
coarse-grained aka issuance policies and
we'll discuss fine-grained policies or
templates in a later video
moving forward i'll be using certificate
issuance policies or issuance policies
to refer to course-grained policies
today we'll learn how and when to use a
certificate issuance policy
as we discussed a certificate issuance
policy defines controls over all
certificate issuance within a ca pool
a ca manager can attach a certificate
issuance policy to a ca pool to define
restrictions on the kind of certificates
that the cas in the ca pool can issue
you can specify the certificate issuance
policy while creating a ca pool or by
updating an existing ca pool
certificate issuance policies allow you
to add constraints on the allowed
subject and subject alternative names or
sans that can be requested
this validates that the correct identity
is an issued certificates and can define
restrictions on variables like
certificate lifetimes key types and
certificate request modes
additionally it lets you append specific
x.509 extensions into all issued
certificates whether or not they were in
the certificate request
so when should you use a certificate
issuance policy
well a good rule of thumb is if one or
both of the following cases apply
one your ca pool is intended to issue
certificates according to a single
well-defined profile
meaning it's only going to do one thing
for example if you have a dedicated ca
pool for each issuance scenario in your
organization
like each product group manages their
own ca pools that are completely
distinct from other use cases
two you want to define a common baseline
for x.509 extensions and additional
restrictions that apply to all the
certificate issuance profiles used with
this ca pool
in other words if your ca pool will be
issuing more than one certificate
profile but all the certificate profiles
have something in common
like max certificate lifetime or
opinionated requirements for key types
before you begin creating your issuance
policy make sure you have the ca service
operation manager or ca service admin
iam role
you can use this quick start to get
step-by-step instructions on how to
create a cua pool and use this link for
detailed instructions on adding a
certificate issuance policy file to an
existing ca pool right in the console or
command line
now let's take a look at some supported
issuance policy restrictions that you
can combine to build an issuance policy
for example one we'll take a look at
restricting or forcing allowed x.509
values
a ca pool can restrict which x.509
extensions can be specified by callers
and certificate requests by configuring
the passthrough extensions field it can
also explicitly specify x.509 extension
values to be added to all its issued
certificates overwriting any requested
values by using the baseline values
field
baseline values allow to specify key
usage ca options certificate policy
identifiers ocsp servers and or other
xtop 509 extensions
if you update any part of the baseline
values field the update replaces the
entire set of values in the field
for example you can restrict a ca to
issue only end entity certificates with
x.509 values for mutual tls or mtls
restricting the issuance controls to
only what is expected is a good
principle to follow to avoid accidental
or malicious issuance of unexpected
certificates
for example two we'll look at
restricting allowed identity fields
if you need to restrict the identity of
certificates issued through a ca pool
you can add a common expression language
or cel expression to the issuance
policies identity constraints field the
cel expressions allow arbitrary
restrictions over the subject
distinguished name including the common
name and the sans of a certificate
this code shows how to allow the ca to
issue only certificates matching a
specified subject in this case requiring
the organization being example llc and
the country code being either the us or
uk
this means certificates will only be
issued identifying this specific company
in one of these two countries
take note that the actual value of cel
expression is in the nested expression
field in the line under it
to learn more about all the supported
restrictions for issuance policies check
out the link in the description thanks
for tuning in to learn about policy
controls for cas and some options
available for certificate issuance
policies that allow for more
customization in line with your needs to
learn more about cas and issuance
policies check out the helpful links in
the description
and if you're enjoying learning about
cis don't forget to subscribe to our
channel where we put out more great
content each week thanks for watching